I thanks for joining me I'm Tara Smith
I'm an infectious disease epidemiologist
I wrote a column for Quantum magazine
about how our existing knowledge of
coronaviruses
can potentially help us inform knowing
under understanding what's going on with
the kovin 19 pandemic and so I'm here
today on the quantum magazine YouTube
channel to answer some additional
questions that have come in so can you
explain it in simple terms like Ovid 19
wasn't created in the lab I mean first I
think it's it's unlikely that that
happened I know there are some really
big advocates of that but I think what
some people don't don't realize is how
often these spill overs from animals to
people happen okay so there's even a
term for it in kind of the field we
forward to it as viral chatter we know
this happens a lot and and most of these
spill overs are not documented so it
often takes something that is pretty
dramatic like right now like this
coronavirus pandemic or like an Ebola
outbreak a lot of these spill overs are
often dead ends and they're they're
either they don't spread from human to
human so they may go from animal to
person but then not from person to
person
so they die out or they can circulate
maybe undetected for a long time this is
what happened with HIV HIV actually is
not a single spillover event it didn't
happen just once it happened multiple
times with related viruses that's why
they're slightly different that came
from slightly different animals from you
know chimpanzees to City mangaboos to
gorillas again we didn't detect them
initially because they don't cause like
you know symptoms as obvious maybe as
Ebola just based on how everything works
it is much more likely that this is a
natural spillover then something created
in a lab looking at his genome sequence
it doesn't have any markers of being you
know altered by humans I know and after
that was kind of pointed out the other
idea came that well okay but it was in
the lab and then it had just gotten
loose from there which
tougher to rule out but if so it was not
a virus that ever was recorded as being
in that laboratory it was never
identified her sequence I can't say lab
accidents never happened but there's
certainly much less common than just
those natural spill overs from wildlife
reservoirs or other animal reservoirs
into humans it's time to prove a
negative but I think it's much more
likely that it was a natural event than
some kind of a laboratory accident
so that's host a lot of crota viruses is
there something we can learn from the
way bats immune systems handle the virus
and that is kind of a million-dollar
question - that's something that's you
know a lot of people have wanted to know
is because that's Harbor not only you
know coronaviruses but our hosts -
viruses like Ebola and Marburg nipa and
Hendra you know a lot of different
pathogens come from bats and part of
that is because I mean bats just are
incredibly diverse they're yeah we have
so many different species of bats that's
it's not surprising that we get a lot of
spill overs because they just harbor
their own different you know viral
groups those eventually can cause
infections in humans so why don't they
seem to cause harm to bats and what we
don't really know
I mean bats are really hard to work with
in the laboratory they don't really
survive well in captivity so it makes it
difficult to do a lot of experimental
work on them there's also been some
suggestion that just because of the way
bats you know live that they they fly
they have to have a high metabolism so
that they can you know expend that
energy on on flight that might also play
a role in their immune system with
basically their you know fevered all the
time essentially they have a high body
temperature then maybe that is just kind
of keeping the viruses that they have in
check but those are all really more
hypotheses than anything because again
they're just really difficult to test
because we don't have a lot of good
experimental data on some of the bats
how likely is it that we will discover a
really powerful drug that here
coven 19 quickly before a vaccine gets
licensed for widespread use for most of
those drugs not all but most that are
being examined for treatments for coven
19 a lot of them are already in use for
other other infections or other areas so
if we could find something that is
effective and it has already been
licensed for something else it's already
known to be you know relatively safe and
has already gone through all the
approvals it's much easier to take those
and kind of repurpose them for treatment
for Coppa 19 than it is to develop
something completely de novo where you
have to you know determine its safety
profile and and everything else but from
you know the tests we've seen so far and
of course there are many that are
ongoing so so who knows what the outcome
of those will be - I haven't been
particularly impressed with the results
that we've seen so far we saw the
results from some of them from REM des
of year or trials the other day and the
ones in China really didn't go anywhere
the NIH ones that were done here in the
United States seem to maybe show some
progress but that's also an IV drug
which makes it just a lot more difficult
to get to a larger number of people so
if we find one of those that are already
approved for other infections or other
conditions then yes that I think that
those could be in place before we get to
a vaccine how long will it take to
develop herd immunity when you look at
the percent of the population that will
need to be infected by any kind of virus
to develop herd immunity that is based
on how transmissible they are in a
population you would have to have
basically about sixty percent sixty to
seventy percent of the population immune
in order to reach that herd immunity
threshold okay now remember herd
immunity is not like a switch it's not
all or nothing the you know the higher
number of people that you have in the
population that are immune the more
difficult it makes for that virus to
find a susceptible host and to spread so
you know any immunity in the population
is better than none even if it's not
that hard immunity threshold yet so
if we would go over the course of say
you know 12 months sorry and 40% of the
population would have been infected with
SARS coronavirus - in theory 40% of the
population then would be immune but what
if that immunity wanes after a year so
you have the people who were infected at
the very beginning have maybe you know
or maybe no longer functionally immune
so you're not really at 40% of the
population anymore you're at a lower
level than that so those are some of the
questions that we we just don't have
answers to and we won't have answers we
just can't have answers without
following people over time so it's only
something that we will know after you
know one year or three years how long
that immunity lasts and if people are
really protected from reinfection or not
a lot of health care workers are dying
from koban statistically speaking could
this be because of higher original
exposure that's one of the hypotheses
for the reasons why why some of these
health care workers are coming down with
not only illness but in some cases
really severe illness even though there
otherwise seems to be kind of young and
healthy is that exposure to a higher
load of virus and especially a higher
load of aerosolized virus they also did
see this with SARS especially in the
early days before again before it was
recognized and and before measures were
taken to to really use like n95
respirators and things like that to
protect healthcare workers that there
did seem to be kind of a dose exposure
there that's more virus you were exposed
to more severe symptoms you could get
and we have a little bit of evidence of
that from the early days in China also
again when health care workers were
exposed to this before understanding
what it was that's using again and 95
respirators and face masks and things
like that to protect healthcare workers
did seem to decrease their mortality as
an incidence of serious infection from
that as well so we think maybe again
that we that's something that will be
better resolved with good animal models
and animal experiments
where you can directly challenge them
with different doses of the virus and
look at the severity of their outcomes
so that's something that I'm sure will
be coming from some of these animal
studies please check out quantum
Magazine org and subscribe to the
YouTube channel where they have a lot of
other QAS with other scientists so thank
you for joining and stay safe out there
take care of each other thank you